Traduttore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Revisore: Federico Sangati
Buongiorno a tutti voi.
Benvenuti ancora,
anche da parte di noi strumentisti,
che siamo un po' l'elemento
anomalo di questa giornata.
Io eseguirò un vecchio brano, del 2012.
All'epoca, era il mio secondo tentativo
di provare a trattare la forma canzone
come un piccolo cortometraggio.
Pensare a una prima
e a una seconda strofa,
come se fossero il vecchio
primo e secondo tempo di un film.
E magari cercare di farlo
senza una sceneggiatura troppo lineare,
magari con un montaggio
un po' più interessante,
un po' più articolato,
dove i personaggi viventi
di una prima strofa, di un prologo,
venissero poi definiti
solo a fine narrazione.
Il brano appartiene
al mio primo disco, Fiori e Demoni,
si chiama Acqua.
Grazie.
(Applausi)
(Musica di chitarra)
♪ Il venditore afgano
ha visto esploder gambe ♪
♪ Anche di suo fratello
e odia perché ne ha bisogno ♪
♪ Il giovane italiano
pensa che sia un coglione ♪
♪ Che questo non ha senso,
non è valida ragione ♪
♪ Peccato che domenica
ha infilato sei centimetri di lama ♪
♪ Dentro a un petto
che batteva per un'altra squadra ♪
♪ Che ha incrociato
la sua strada e non doveva ♪
♪ Che sgarro imperdonabile ♪
♪ E Irina vende il corpo,
ma solo più da tergo ♪
♪ Non vuole occhi davanti
a far da specchio del suo inferno ♪
♪ E tu che a malapena
hai il tuo smalto da abbinare ♪
♪ Pensi di capire? ♪
♪ Acqua, acqua, non vedi manco il sole ♪
♪ Figurati il mio cuore, acqua, acqua ♪
♪ Non trovi due parole
scolpite nella pietra ♪
♪ Acqua, acqua, non vedi manco il sole ♪
♪ Figurati il mio amore, acqua, acqua ♪
♪ Non trovi due parole,
due semplici parole ♪
♪ Lo sbirro quello buono,
si è fatto qualche pista ♪
♪ Ma toglie dalla strada
e li rimette sulla giusta ♪
♪ puttane e ragazzini,
destini già segnati ♪
♪ si occupa degli altri
e si dimentica i suoi cari ♪
♪ Peccato che domenica,
col manganello pronto ♪
♪ Ha visto suo fratello
accoltellato da uno stronzo ♪
♪ Ed ha corso quanto più poteva ♪
♪ Ma era tardi, che ironia la sorte ♪
♪ E Irina ci ha creduto,
nella sua redenzione ♪
♪ Ma lascia la comunità,
ritorna al marciapiede ♪
♪ E tu che a malapena
hai le tue scarpe da abbinare ♪
♪ Pensi di capire? ♪
♪ Acqua, acqua, non vedi manco il sole ♪
♪ Figurati il mio cuore, acqua, acqua ♪
♪ Non trovi due parole
scolpite nella pietra ♪
♪ Acqua, acqua, non vedi manco il sole ♪
♪ Figurati il mio amore, acqua, acqua ♪
♪ Non trovi due parole,
due cazzo di parole ♪
♪ Acqua, acqua, non vedi manco il sole ♪
♪ Figurati il mio cuore, acqua, acqua ♪
♪ Non trovi due parole
scolpite nella pietra ♪
♪ Acqua, acqua, non vedi manco il sole ♪
♪ Figurati il mio amore, acqua, acqua ♪
♪ Non trovi due parole,
due semplici parole. ♪
(Applausi)
Grazie mille, grazie infinite,
grazie a TEDxTorino per l'invito.
(Applausi)